what's going on michelle when i was
younger i was sexually abused by my
brothers
by both of them and um
i'm so sorry my mom knew what was going
on
and my brothers
they've apologized to me about it later
in life
and my mom admitted that she knew what
was going on but she
didn't know what to do but um my issue
is
um what i still one of my brothers
still continued on his behaviors he um
has been watching child pornography and
um
and he's done really messed up things
with
my dog and he's also basically assaulted
me three years ago
um and i ended up having a miscarriage
forward um but
i'm sorry i'm like i can't have to catch
my breath
i've really you know i only have one mom
and i really miss her
and i haven't walked a moment like a
year i moved out of my house
it was my parents house and they just
don't know
where to go from here or like
yeah this is a lot michelle so
this this is awful and evil and
a bunch of different levels here and
i'm gonna speak real directly and honest
with you okay
okay are you hearing me yes
i'm gonna be real direct with you number
one
right when this call is over you will
hang up the phone
and you will call the police on your
brother for watching child pornography
period okay okay
that isn't a negotiable thing we are
going to send
we are going to call somebody here and
so you can beat us to the punch
but when i know about something about
children being hurt children being
exploited or abused
i'm making that call and i expect every
person whether it's your mom your
brother your dad your husband i don't
care who it is
to make that call and so right when we
get off this phone you're gonna make
that call
okay okay this is about you
reclaiming control about what's right
and you taking quote unquote the power
back in your life
number two your brother apologize your
other brother apologized to you
for sexually assaulting you as kids
good for him that does not mean that he
has permission to waltz back into your
life
that you owe him any sort of
relationship any sort of connection
anything like that
you michelle are in control of the story
you michelle are in control of what
happens next
okay okay and for somebody who's been
abused in the way you have been
your whole life people have taken from
you and taken and taken and taken
and you're gonna have to get with a
professional
immediately okay immediately
to begin walking back that trauma when
it comes to your mom
your mom committed what i think is one
of the most egregious evils a parent can
do
which is she let her child be hurt
and just watched it happen
yeah i'm not gonna judge your mom
because i don't know what her life
history is
i don't know what evils were done to her
i know there was something super toxic
going on in your home
for this to be going on the way it has
been
and i'm sure we could talk for hours as
you unpacked your childhood
but what your mom did to you is wrong
she not only abandoned you she sets you
up for a lifetime
of hurt and trauma and pain and evil
and of course you miss your mom but you
miss the fantasy of your mom more than
you miss your mom
yeah i do i miss i miss like having a
mom and
you know what when i always pictured
like a mom to be you know
for me and here's what really sucks
michelle i told you i was going to tell
you the truth
you didn't get that mom you deserved
that mom you should have got that mom
and you didn't get that mom
and so as you sit in the ash of that and
you've been sitting in these ashes for a
long time you just thought those ashes
were trees and grass
they weren't they were
grit and concrete and
blood-stained dirt ash
and now what you have to do the work you
have to do
is to get with a professional today
and this call is happening between us in
the morning
and so you've got all day to find
somebody
go find a professional who's going to
walk a journey with you and your journey
is going to be longer than most
i have a question john yeah my mom yeah
she apologized she said excellent
good for her i'm glad she apologized
good for her and i'm all about
redemption
i'm all about people changing and
growing and moving on
but she hurts you in a way that your
soul
and your brain and your body are going
to be recovering for years and years and
years
because if you can't trust your mom to
show up and stop evil who
in god's name can you trust
right yeah right i don't know a lot
about the world but i know the world's a
crummy place sometimes and that's why
moms and dads are there
to protect children
and your mom didn't show up
when my brother when he assaulted me
three years ago when he physically
assaulted me for years ago
my mom i called the police and i was
leaving at my parents house at that time
good for her good for hey listen listen
listen
i want you to hear what you're doing
which is classic
abuse survivor behavior you're trying to
make everyone else okay
you're trying to come up with excuses
and reasons why you shouldn't hurt so
bad
why they're not quite as bad as it seems
on paper
and here's the thing 20 years ago 30
years ago
maybe your mom is a radically different
human being she's a vigilante now
she has high support
she is take no crap off anybody
burn all of them down who hurt my baby
girl maybe that's why she is awesome
good for her you still have healing to
do
that you cannot do if you are tethered
to her right now
that doesn't mean that your
relationship's over forever
but it does mean for a season there's
got to be some space and separation
because you don't even know what healthy
love looks like
feels like you don't know what that
sidewalk feels like when you walk on it
and it's totally firm
and it's safe you don't know what green
grass and trees feel like and smell like
your body has never experienced a flower
because you've been living
in ash and so today
you're going to call the police on your
brother
for continuing to perpetuate child
pornography today you're going to call a
therapist and say
for the first time in a long time i'm
going to take care of me
i need help and what's going to happen
over time is you're going to work to
establish relationships
with the women in your community that
you trust
that will become surrogate moms to you
that will lean into your life
that will honor you and will cherish you
and will protect you
will give you wisdom give you safety
and then when you get tethered into
those relationships then you will be
safe enough
to maybe maybe
invite your mom out for coffee and say
hi how are you
because you're going to know strength
then you're going to know safety then
that you have
never felt never known brother's job
is to burn the world down for his little
sister not to abuse her
the other brother's job
is to knock the teeth out of the older
brother who abuses my sister
not to join in and the mom's job
is to burn it all down for my daughter
not to turn my head the other way
michelle
i'm so sorry you deserved more than this
and i don't mean this trite and i don't
mean this disrespectfully
there is healing on the other side of
this and it's going to be a
hard exhausting road which means you got
to get people around you that you trust
and will care for you but there is
healing on the other way
and it starts with that phone call the
9-1-1 it starts with that phone call to
a therapist
it starts with you finding a friend or
another woman in your community where
you
work at your church letting her know
here's what happened to me here's my
childhood
and i need someone to lean on in the
next year in the next two years
because i've got a long road to walk
so as you make this journey michelle as
you make these calls as you start
leaning into the
the future here we're here for you
shoot me an email give me a call we'll
have you back on the show talk about how
your progress is going
make no mistake it's going to be ugly
and messy your mom didn't get a vote
your brothers don't get a vote your dad
didn't get a vote
none of those people who hurt you get a
vote
it's time you put on your oxygen mask
michelle and start taking care of you
and it starts today